[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
do you want to give my condolences to
the floyd family one year after he's
convicted in the murder of george floyd
derek shogun appeals his conviction but
first it's johnny depp versus amber
heard based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that they were that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage we take a closer look at
herd's washington post article plus has
heard met her donation pledge to the
aclu so it's fair to say that she has
not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu true that's right and later
depp's business manager breaks down the
divorce settlement she was demanding 14
million 250 000
of consideration
and then it got worse law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer amber
heard's washington post op-ed takes
center stage in the defamation lawsuit
brought on by ex-husband johnny depp law
and crime's angel levy is at the fairfax
county courthouse where jurors heard
first-hand accounts of the events
leading up to the article's debut
amber heard's december 2018 washington
post op-ed was written in part by
lawyers from the aclu heard had become
an aclu ambassador after agreeing to
donate half of her divorce settlement
from johnny depp to the organization
now based on my review of prior drafts
of the op-ed i knew that they were that
that she was referring to johnny depp in
her marriage aclu general counsel
terence dougherty was deposed last
december this is the online version of
the op-ed in which heard described being
a survivor of sexual violence and
domestic abuse
she wrote that two years prior in 2016
she had become a public figure
representing domestic abuse there were
emails between herds camp and the aclu
about how much johnny depp should be
mentioned and isn't it true that ms
heard's advisors initially revised the
draft to remove any reference to ms
heard's marriage or divorce i
recall a number of email communications
back and forth among aclu personnel and
ms herds
attorneys
where they were
suggesting edits to the op-ed relating
to
matters covered in the nda and then is
it also true that there were some at the
aclu who expressed their belief that
excising those references to
her marriage and divorce
from johnny depp made
the op-ed less impactful correct
it is correct that is correct the op-ed
was pitched to a number of publications
and she writes hey michael wondering if
we might interest you in a piece by
amber heard who as you may recall was
beaten up during her brief marriage to
johnny depp
on what the incoming congress can do to
help protect women in similar situations
did i read that correctly yes you read
it correctly as you know by now the
op-ed was published in december 2018.
the timing according to doherty's
testimony was important to amber heard
ms heard said in words or substance that
she wanted the op-ed to come out
soon after aquaman correct i believe
that's correct amber heard's team
maintains that she told the truth in
that op-ed so no defamation occurred
coming up later we're going to tell you
about just how much amber heard has
donated to the aclu and how elon musk is
involved reporting from fairfax county
virginia i'm angenette levy for law and
crime daily
thanks anja joining us today is defense
attorney jack rice and co-host terry
austin jack the way this op-ed was
pitched it is as clear as day that depp
is the one being accused of abuse but so
far the evidence suggests that heard
wasn't physically abused now if she
shows up on the stand and says this was
emotional abuse does that win her the
case
well probably not because really what
this is about at this point is
credibility and credibility cuts across
everything that she does and everything
that she says and so when we think about
all of the witnesses that have already
appeared the cross-examination as well
as direct examination of johnny depp
himself some of the other experts as
well as what she brings herself and
we're still waiting for that i think
that issue really really matters and so
if we think about just how compelling
she can be here the fact that she may
pivot and say it wasn't physical it was
something else then all of a sudden it
changes so i think it's really important
that she come back with that credibility
piece at this point i think she has
failed to do that the depth team is
doing a very very good job yeah i would
100 agree with you jack i might slide in
on top of credibility likability as well
that's another issue i think that's an
issue here good point
terry the aclu witness also discussed
the draft of the washington post op-ed
did that testimony help depp's
defamation claim
absolutely terence doherty he's the
general counsel and the ceo of aclu and
that testimony definitely supported the
defamation claim it connects the op-ed
piece to johnny depp specifically even
though the amber herd team is saying he
wasn't named it's no question he was
named this witness told the jury that
heard was appointed as an ambassador to
aclu that the aclu discussed this
article with her that they talked back
and forth as far as the draft was
concerned about johnny depp and that
herd's lawyers took out the specific
reference so there's no question that
they were referring to johnny depp
there's no question that washington post
knew that and in fact other articles in
other publications connected johnny depp
to that police so definitely a good
witness yeah we're starting to really
see this case connect at so many levels
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they finish uh their case that being
johnny depp's attorneys thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily our
coverage of the dep herd defamation suit
continues we take a closer look at the
video deposition about herd's donation
for the aclu was the full 3.5 million
dollars paid off
[Music]
welcome back we continue coverage now in
the defamation case of johnny depp
versus amber hurd on thursday testimony
zeroed in on herd's work as an aclu
ambassador and her pledge to donate 3.5
million dollars to the organization
council for the acu revealed heard has
not donated since 2018 or met that 3.5
million dollar pledge amount
because you've already testified that ms
heard was not the original source of the
funds
for the 500 000 vanguard contribution
correct
we received that 500 000 from vanguard
their 501c3 not from any other
person
right but vanguard was associated with
mr musk true we believe that to be the
case yes okay
so after
this december 2018
donation
has misheard made any
donations directly or indirectly to the
aclu
no though those are the four
contributions the one that we've
developed for that we've discussed
well we're almost
three years since her last contribution
what if any
efforts has the aclu
made
to get amber hurt to pay
um we reached out to
her
we um
reached out to ms hurd starting in 2019
for the next um installment of her
giving and
we
learned that she was having financial
difficulties
terry council for depth spent a long
time talking about contributions from
herd to the aclu how important do you
think that is to this case
look i think it's important to say look
she pledged all of this money to both
the aclu and to the children's hospital
of la but i don't think they should just
keep going over that point no question
she paid 350 direct
debt paid 100 000 vanguard end or musk
paid 500 and fidelity which may or may
not be heard paid 350 000 for a total of
1.3 but here's the point she pledged
three five she never signed the pledge
agreement she had financial difficulties
and if you know anything about
charitable giving you pledge if you
don't sign the agreement it's a give get
who cares if somebody else paid it so
the point is i think she pledged it she
didn't pay it but i would not make such
a big deal about it yeah and jack that
kind of bleeds into my question and we
kind of talked about this already
earlier
i think it's about credibility and
likability but the question here is are
they kind of beating the dead horse with
this issue of credibility and likability
or do you think it's helping deb's case
well you know i i may disagree and the
reason is is i'm thinking about it in
two ways is that i'm thinking of the
narrative that i'm trying to establish
here one of those narratives is about
this question of honesty in other words
is does she lie to you the second one
has to do with authenticity and what i'm
talking about was when she makes a
promise to give this money she doesn't
give it but that's not the big issue
the biggest issue has to do with her
willingness and desire to sort of become
the voice of the metoo movement and then
she doesn't even bother to come forward
with the money that she promises for
that metoo movement which brings to
question the real viability of her
actually being that voice or ever caring
to be that voice she is an opportunist
she is a liar those are my big arguments
that i'm making if i'm representing the
depth team and her failure to pay and
her unwillingness to support this cause
supports those very claims
jack with talk like that i think that i
think the debt team is going to be
calling you for some assistance uh
sometime soon that's an interesting
point and i tend to agree i like that
angle we'll see if they bring it up on
closing arguments in this case
still ahead on law and crime daily our
coverage of the johnny depp versus amber
heard defamation trial continues johnny
depp's business manager takes the stand
why he says he was reprimanded by herds
legal team
[Music]
welcome back we're diving deeper into
the breakdown of johnny depp and amber
hurd's relationship on thursday depp's
business manager testified to the amount
heard asked for as part of a divorce
settlement
she initially was looking for a
consideration of four million dollars
but her demand continually increased
it went from four million dollars to
five million dollars
then it went from five million dollars
to five and a half million dollars
then it went to seven million dollars
and then
it was seven million dollars and she
required demanded that mr depp also pay
five hundred thousand dollars to her
attorneys so the next demand
was that all the community liabilities
that were unresolved approximately 13.5
million dollars
that mr depp had to pay those
liabilities in its entirety
so at that point
she was demanding 14 million 250 000
of consideration
and then it got worse
the next demand
was that all of this consideration
be paid to her free of taxation
all right jack so far you've been
turning water into wine with these
answers let me throw this one at you on
the stand white testified that he was
reprimanded by herds legal team for
making settlement payments to the aclu
instead of straight to her so what do
you think depp's attorneys are trying to
get out there
yeah because she wasn't going to give it
to the aclu anyway right i mean this
wasn't ever about that this is about a
gold digger who just wants more and more
and more and more by the way you didn't
mention they were married for 15 months
so let me get this right 15 months 14
million
post tax so in other words we're talking
about 25 million pre-tax based upon what
and you start asking this fundamental
question about what is it that she's
actually about
this supports that contention she is an
opportunist and this is another witness
that you pile on there to say it's not
just one witness it's a bunch of each
thread wrapped together weaved into a
rope you want to put right around her
and say see it's what she is come on you
know it's true
i don't know jack as your talk i can
hear a very specific kanye west song
playing in my head i won't say which one
it is exactly but terry court is dark on
fridays and we expect herd's team to
start their case early next week what
are your thoughts on depp's case so far
my thought is so far so good look we
have not heard amber heard's case but we
have heard johnny depp so far every
single witness is in love with johnny
from all of his security guards to the
people who work around him to his nurses
to his doctors he is a good man he
treats people well they don't see that
he is in any way shape or form abusing
anybody physically yes he will beat up a
cabinet or two but he has not been
violent as far as concerns amber so i
definitely think he's put on a good case
and the defamation piece is good too
these last witnesses have really
established the fact that his reputation
has been harmed and it was directly
caused by that washington post article
yeah hey right now the evidence for
depth looks strong but i would hesitate
to say that the case is all but one
because
herd still has to put on her case and
every case looks good until you see the
other side so we'll continue with our
coverage here of the johnny depp versus
amber hurd case going forward thank you
both and in dallas texas both sides rest
in the case of accused serial killer
billy shamirmir but not before the
prosecution shared video surveillance
footage and cell phone records
connecting the defendant to the crimes
he's charged with shamirmir is on trial
for the murder of 81 year old lou harris
an elderly woman who police say was
smothered while being robbed in her own
home authorities say harris isn't his
only victim in total he's charged with
the deaths of 18 seniors all but one are
women prosecutors believe chamiramir
posed as a maintenance or health care
worker to gain access to people's homes
they say he stole from them and sold
their valuables on the reselling app
offer up prosecutors played walmart
surveillance footage for the jury
showing shamir mir and harris shopping
at this store checking out then leaving
around the same time on march 20 2018
the same day harris was killed
prosecutors say he spotted harris while
shopping followed her home before
smothering her with a pillow and
stealing her jewelry box on wednesday a
juror saw footage also from walmart on a
different day before another alleged
victim mary brooks was killed an fbi
digital forensic analyst testified cell
phone records placed shamir mir at
several locations connected to the crime
the jury's seen evidence that billy chu
miyamir and lou harris were at walmart
at court and arapaho
around 3 30 on march 20.
okay yes sir um
lou harris was found dead
with her groceries still out
and
two hours later billy chamber was in her
possession was in possession of her
items including a jewelry box her keys
and other items with the analysis of
your cell phone records in a scenario
provided be consistent with a cell phone
device leaving six six zero nine more
breeze
traveling down for arapahoe towards
beltline
up towards billy chamber's home at 4 500
pair ridge yes sir as i stated earlier i
don't have records covering the time so
i can't say the fuck god never got
records that show using a tower that
covers blue hair's address but that
movement yes sir
that would be consist that scenario
would be consistent with these cell
phone records that you have of billy
commander yes sir
would what we just walked through on
january 30th march 15th march 19th march
20th be a prime example of that what
just happened
yes sir you know other evidence that's
discovered cooperates or by cell site
cooperates the other evidence
women come back a judge issues an order
for no cameras allowed in the george
floyd state case for three former
officers in minneapolis plus darren
sherwood appeals his murder conviction
in the death of george floyd that's next
on long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back turning to news out of
minneapolis as the state trial of three
former minneapolis police officers
charge in the killing of george floyd
will not be live-streamed the judge
overseeing the state trial previously
allowed the live stream of the derek
shogun trial because of the coven 19
pandemic he says the pandemic has waned
and restrictions have been relaxed so
the pandemic can't be used to justify
going against policy on live streaming
trials there will be seats for media in
the courtroom and space set aside for
floyd's family and for family members of
each defendant tao lane and king are
charged with aiding and abetting the
murder of floyd in may 2020. their trial
is set to begin june 13th
and more news involving the george floyd
case as derek shoving is appealing his
murder conviction the former minneapolis
police officer is asking the state court
of appeals to overturn his conviction
for the 2020 murder of george floyd the
82-page appeal lists more than a dozen
reasons his attorneys argue the trial
was tainted including pre-trial
publicity protests and the announcement
of the city's settlement with floyd's
family during jury selection chauvin's
attorneys also accused prosecutors of
misconduct saying they failed to
properly disclose evidence to chauvin's
team the former officer's appeal asked
that the court do one of three things
overturn the conviction order a new
trial in a different venue or reduce
chauvin's sentence to be within the
state sentencing guidelines prosecutors
have not yet responded to the appeal
saying they would save their reply for
court
jack overturned new trial or reduced
sentence those requests come from very
different standards and requests you're
a saint paul minnesota lawyer does it
look like showman has a real chance or
is this just a hail mary
die it's a hail mary i mean the
likelihood of the court of appeals
actually overturning a jury is almost
impossible in this case even if they
come back and say oops that was a
mistake oops that was a mistake what
they will always say is but it was never
enough i mean frankly and truly and
honestly my biggest problem with this
entire process was that one juror who
actually said he had no
position on this need never been to a
protest and then it comes back
subsequently that he was actually in
washington dc at a protest wearing a
shirt that gets your knee off my neck my
problem with that is that what we have
to have here is a really clean trial
because rule of law is important and if
an entire swath of society feels like
they're being treated unfairly then you
got to make sure it's as clean as
possible no excuse no justification but
you don't want anybody on the other side
to be able to point to something and say
oh because of this bad decision this was
a bad jury conclusion we want everybody
to buy in and say this conviction should
stick because he did it and he got a
fair trial i just don't want any hiccups
along the way that makes sense rule of
law i would agree with you on that one
terry do you think the judge made the
correct decision to exclude the media
from this trial
i don't i think the right decision would
have been to allow cameras in the trial
look we had cameras in the original
derek chovin case and that was important
this is one of the biggest cases of the
century the fact that george floyd was
killed in front of all of us and so i do
think the cameras should be there
there's a need for public transparency
so i think wrong decision i would agree
as well well thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you